[Musique]
c'est bercy ce que en fait j'étais en
train ter déplacement merci car il est
stable je suis des quads femme d'à côté
toujours comme ça mais j'ai l'impression
qu'à chaque fois que vous recevez des
gens un petit peu sur le tas et finir en
bout de table mais pas du tout pourquoi
vous servir un verre vous inquiétez pas
c'est vraiment là louis boyard qui est
venu aussi ça vous êtes bien assis quand
même pas bon ça va il est heureux du
meeting d'hier c'était incroyable je
vous sens j'ai rarement vu un quelque
chose aussi incroyable des paroles de la
reconquête c'est ça forcément quand on
porte la parole on est content ah non
mais en victime d'hier qui nous a rendu
heureux ah ouais avoir quinze mille
personnes comme ça la salle en délire le
maire faut que j'ai vu quelque chose
comme ça c'était les meetings de sarkozy
en 2006
analytics et vous êtes inspiré de
sarkozy non bah on s'inspire des
meilleures ah ouais au niveau des
meetings en tout cas ouais c'est vrai
c'est vraiment c'est votre vous savez on
travaille et qu'olivier ubéda qui est un
de ceux qui organisaient les outils de
sarkozy est exactement alors vous êtes
pour vous c'est c'est réussi ah c'est un
succès incroyable incroyable
inconsciente et que ça va bouger dans
les sondages ça va faire je pense que la
semaine d'avant j'ai vu le dernier
sondage que j'ai donné oui oui alors
d'ailleurs me par contre on a le harris
interactive qui est sorti aussi
aujourd'hui corps qui ne prend pas en
compte le meeting où il me fait remonter
d'ailleurs déjà d'un point et kim et
valérie pécresse d'armes d'accord ah oui
mais les sondages c'est quand on va voir
ça va vous savoir où ça bouge tout le
temps 1 c'est comme ici les chroniqueurs
non mais c'est vrai vous avez au pot
alors oui boyard est avec nous et c'est
vrai que hier on a beaucoup parlé du
meeting viens d'en parler longuement et
il ya aussi les événements qui se sont
parlés se passer dans ce meeting on va
revoir quand vous voulez vous montrer
cette image de la militante de sos
racisme juste après l'émeute elle avait
reçu de nombreux coups de la part de
militants regardez son et en sortant du
meeting
on est des antiracistes convaincu on est
venu pour dire que tout le monde n'était
pas d'accord je
[Musique]
l'ignoré
je pensais qu'on est en démocratie qu'on
pouvait donc dire qu'on avait à dire et
qu'on n'aurait pas de conséquence sauf
physique n'est pas revue qui s'était
passé des paroles que tu
étais des lettres qu'ils aient la phrase
non au racisme
alors c'est vrai qu'on a vu on a vu les
images rien un instant de ses militants
dont qu'elle soit raciste qui s'étaient
levés s'était mis sur sur des chaises
garenne quand vous voyez ça qu'est ce
que vous dites mais il ya un truc c'est
que ces militants sos racisme sont venus
accompagnés des milices d'extrême gauche
antifa et il était venu pour se battre
il était venu exactement pour ça et ils
ont eu exactement ce qu'ils voulaient
nous ce qui s'est passé alors pour vous
parce que votre version on aura la
version cc pas à moi j'étais dans la
salle j'ai vu ce qui s'est passé ils
étaient venus pour se battre il voulait
absolument à voir ces images pour
pourrir le meeting et militante de sos
racisme et mais étaient revenus avec des
antilles fin ils étaient venus
accompagner dans tifa de milices
d'extrême gauche extrêmement violente ce
qui avait d'ailleurs attaqué eric
zemmour quand il avait fait son
déplacement à marseille il y avait 500
antifa qui avait mis la ville de
marseille a fait à 100 le week-end
dernier quand il avait lu le déplacement
de d'eric zemmour ou confirmés oui tout
à fait six étaient venus exactement pour
convoquer des images violentes et je
crois de façon qu'ils n'avaient pas leur
place dans ce dans ce meeting d'ailleurs
on a une photo on a une photo de ces
gens 17 raciste qui peut ce qu'une photo
sur facebook juste après tout sourire en
disant after avec le sourire sos racisme
je vous dis on invitait tout le monde la
souris ce racisme et tous les militants
qui étaient là-bas d'associatifs aucun
nous nous a répondu
positivement à notre invitation ça ça
nous un petit peu déçu chez le passeur a
toujours été à fond avec elle c'est bien
parce que à mon poste c'est un bien sûr
c'est un clin d'oeil soit on les avait
déjà invité les attend jour des fonds
grain on a toujours été avec eux on a
toujours été à leur gala on a toujours
tout fait et c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas un
qui a répondu voilà par la positive à
notre à notre invitation ni dans les
dirigeants les personnes les biens
a dit non apparemment mais il a dit
qu'il ne viendrait pas voilà ce soir
donc bravo à eux en tout cas c'est con
parce qu'on aurait aimé avoir péri oui
on a lui alors on a honoré d'avoir la
version malheureusement on l'aura pas
voilà donc c'est un petit peu qu'on voit
là de leur part je suis quand même assez
choqué alors vous vous y étiez moi
j'étais pas dans le meeting parce que
c'était impossible d'y rentrer moi
j'étais fait qu'il est en train de
prendre une glace à côté moi j'étais au
tour à l'endroit où on venait manifester
parce que voilà démocratie bien sûr ce
qu'on ait des charges on se prenait tout
ça mais là vraiment ce qui vous chagrine
et des voitures non mais bah oui bien
sûr j'ai une tête à brûler des voitures
mais c'est pas ton premier mensonge ce
qui me choque quand même c'est que la
même prendre un peu de recul sur ce qui
est en train de se passer là ça fait à
peine 24 heures que la campagne d'eric
zemmour est lancé et on est en train
d'avoir un débat pour savoir si c'est
justifiable la violence sur les
militants pacifistes sos racisme surtout
qu'ils n'étaient pas placés ce que je
sais ce que c'est que eric zemmour c'est
quelqu'un qui d'habitude est très très
bavard hélas il n'a pas communiqué sur
sa à n'importe quel autre époque à 9 ans
avec n'importe quel autre personnage
directement la personne aurait
communiqué pour dire ce qui s'est passé
n'est pas excusable ça ne se reproduira
pas et les militants sur la sanction la
taille là ça n'a pas été fait mais la
différenciation lavier saxon ce que je
dis c'est que eric zemmour s'il se tait
c'est parce que d'un certain mais d'une
certaine manière il laisse planer le
doute et ça ce n'est pas responsable et
donc là encore plus choqué de voir que
vous qui êtes communiquant d'eric
zemmour qui donc derrière un vélo compte
twitter et qui pouviez communiquer sur
sa vous êtes plus occupés à essayer de
changer de sujet pour essayer de dire
ces barrières la semitan extrême gauche
mais bien sûr les gens qui brûlent des
voitures je condamne tous ne le
condamnent mais vous essayez de changer
de sujet alors qu'en fait ça fait deux
jours que tout le monde attend que juste
vous comportiez ans responsables
politiques et si jamais en 24 heures de
campagne vous avez été capable de mettre
le débat dans cet état et que vous êtes
capable de faire planer un doute comme
ça vous
plaît s'il vous plaît juste nicolas
pernikoff vous vous vous eu si vous êtes
choqués par ce qui justifie venait pas
choqués par ce qu'ils ont enfilé est
vrai qu'en voulait que ça se termine
c'est une ambiance électrique vous avez
des gens qui viennent c'est comme si
vous aviez génération identitaire qui
allaient un mythique jean luc mélenchon
vous pensez qu'il va se passer quoi vous
pensez que les gens vont bon juste
rester intérieur est millionnaire je
crois au débat et je crois en cette
émission était pmp aujourd'hui c'est la
seule émission sociétal on peut discuter
ensemble et d'ailleurs et c'est bien
dommage que dominique sopo pardon un
sursis sur l'a6 à bien d'un jour où il
aurait dû être là c'est bien aujourd'hui
donc tout est nickel
il est très important d'être là
aujourd'hui enfin sujet c'est essentiel
d'être là aujourd'hui surtout après ce
qui s'est passé mais comment rouler que
ça ce que que peut-il se passer d'autres
cette violence
est bien sûr chez accor évidemment ce
qui justifie sont évidemment les
partisans de 2,0 et c'est très dommage
que ce qu'ils soient pas là et cela que
c'est que le canari pour le coup et
répété s'attendre je sais exactement
c'était comme les images qu'il faut
qu'ils voulaient récupérer donc l'on
fait c'est terrible c'est
contre-productif et une fois de plus on
ne pas quoi que de ça et s'est séparé
fin il fallait le justifier et excusez
moi mais quand vous dites qu'ils sont
venus pour ce pur se castagner jalu les
odeurs j'ai un gros doute parce que vous
voulez
ces salons sécurité ont trouvé sur les
gens qui essaient d'entrer on a trouvé
chez de couteau d'une matraque
télescopique de gazeuse un taser divers
barres de fer et bouts de bois et plus
de 10 cocktails molotov sur la police en
effet revenue pour cetto je suis très
fier que dans le magma dans mes filles
mais alors qu'est-ce que je fais on a
réussi à infiltrer beaucoup on n'a pas
réussi à tout filtrer il dit cocktails
molotov plus de dix cocktails molotov
ces gens étaient venus pour tuer des
militants d'eric zemmour quand on arrive
j'aurai arrêté mais les taux que les
cocktails molotov vous savez ce que
c'est sûr oui quand on essaie de lancer
des cocktails molotov à l'intérieur d'un
meeting c'est pour tuer des gens
l'extrême gauche étaient venus pour tuer
des militants d'eric zemmour c'est très
grave ce qui se passe quand vous
entendez ça gilles verdez alors moi je
suis choquée par les scènes de violence
mais mais a quand même et à mon avis
c'est pas pour rien si sos racisme que
je connais bien n'est pas là et un petit
côté provocation est roi il ya un petit
côté on vient pour ok donc je suis
choquée parce que les images non de
violences des deux côtés m'ont
absolument scandalisé c'est révoltant
cette jeune femme qui est tapé abbaoui
tabasser ça c'est honteux mais mais pour
moi il ya un côté on vient louis on
vient pour provoquer sinon vous ne venez
pas
non je suis pas daccord d'abord on a le
droit d'aller dans un meeting même
portée pour prouver son hostilité on a
le droit larcher l'a dit on a le voilà
donc il avait le droit après moi
pardonnez moi mais en fait que ce soit
les antifas qui sont archi violent où
certains fafa qui sont archi violent
pardon mais excusez moi monsieur mais
ils tabassent la jeune fille
man show comme bonjour je précise juste
que les entités qui sont venus se battre
la maison vous
n'avez pas la can en entier je pense en
mode on aperçoit les joies et les
antilles sur un kit avec eux qui ont
commencé à attaquer les militants mais
ce qui s'est passé pour ce garçon quand
même et bien sûr c'est honteux mais
jamais on lève la main sur quelqu'un et
on avait mois sur une face à une
obligation et on portera plainte contre
toutes les personnes qui ont fait des
violences pendant ce meeting on portera
plainte contre tout le monde que ce soit
les antifas légende sos racisme et s'il
y avait des gens dans notre public qui
nous soutenaient qu'ils ont acquis on
fait des actions violentes nous portons
plainte contre eux d'avoir du boulot
parce que sur lci sur bfm tv ils ont
montré des gens de votre sécurité qui
ont félicité les mecs qui ont tabassé
les les
positions
sur la question parce que nous voulions
et comme je le répète pour la troisième
fois c'est sos racisme les antifas qui
sont venus pour se battre dans le
meeting et c'est pas nous qui sommes
allés les chercher sûrement pas mais
alors on avait tout intérêt si tout se
passe bien guillaume non mais je suis
désolé alors évidemment les violences ou
les condamner des images sont
extrêmement choquantes mais c'est
suicidaire ce qu'ils ont fait ce sera 6
il ya des endroits où il ne faut pas
aller ou de la même manière on n'y
arrive pas pas si nombreux à choisir la
vérité mais non mais non mais faut dire
la vérité quand vous allez quand vous
allez encore vous allez non droit
d'accord on a vous aller au vélodrome
avec un rayon du psg mais c'est que vous
avez vous faire emmerder quand vous
allez dans un meeting ou non mais je ne
justifie pas ça mais je dis juste que
voilà ça devait arriver et de la
violence j'en ai vu des deux côtés car
mon conjoint
cherchez la violence déjà on a vu des
deux côtés on a aussi vu eric zemmour se
faire agresser et voilà je dis juste que
c'est d ici c'était inévitable voilà il
ya des endroits où on sait que quand on
y va en avant les problèmes s'il vous
plaît alors on va on va passer oui car
il voulait c'est grace kelly guille non
mais oh ouais ça veut dire qu'elle
amènera douala et ça vient de dire
virale à des zones de non de france le
l'endroit en deux mots et une zone de
transit
moi j'entends ce que vous dites sur les
antifas moi j'ai jamais cautionner la
violence d'où qu'elle vienne et
effectuant des gens d'extrême gauche qui
sont violents mais je pense que vous
faites une confusion sos racisme est né
dans les années 80 ils n'ont jamais mené
d'action violente donc ne fait pas la
confusion entre les antifas c'est vrai
sauf facile il songe à des interactions
m'entraîne qui joue la compétition n'est
pas vrai ils sont venus au 6 avenue main
dans la main les ss légende et sos
racisme et les antifas sont vus ensemble
dans la salle entre ceux qui n'en ont
pas du tout vous savez vous là du tout
on sait très bien ils sont arrivés à la
fin de vos débuts du meeting quand on
avait fini de faire entrer tout le monde
ils sont rentrés discrètement par
derrière qu'on avait plus personne
antifa sos racisme ensemble et il était
venu pour se battre parce qu'il voulait
avoir ces images pour qu'on dise qu'il y
avait des violences nous on voulait tous
au début c'était un match organisé le
premier grand meeting d'eric zemmour
vous pensez qu'on veut ça mais sûrement
pas c'est ce qu'on voulait ils sont
venus exprès pour se battre pour avoir
ces images pour après dire vous voyez
c'est pareil l'extrême gauche extrême
droite